and the negative is female and the order
and the yes and the positive is male and
a lot of these things that I have a lot
of trouble uh accepting hi there Steve
Kaufman here and today I'm going to talk
on a different subject I'm going to talk
a bit about a book that I bought called
uh 10 rules for life excuse me 12 rules
for life by Jordan Peterson remember if
you enjoy these videos please subscribe
click on the bell for notifications if
you follow me on a podcast service
please leave a comment
so I'm going to talk about this book and
I'll tell you why and I'm going to
relate it a bit to language learning
because that's what I always like to do
so I became aware of Jordan Peterson
when he was quite controversial because
he opposed the sort of he he was a
professor okay step back a bit professor
at the University of Toronto professor
of psychology the university said you
now have to use these gender neutral
pronouns he said I'm not going to use
General gender neutral pronouns you
can't tell me how to speak or how to use
the language and he has become a leading
figure and sort of opposing what is
known as woke ISM in other words the
idea that everyone has to confirm
conform to certain patterns of behavior
regarding you know gender categories or
race relations or
attitudes towards a whole number of
things that this is the accepted correct
way of Behaving and anyone who doesn't
behave in this way is therefore a bad
person and not welcome at a university
and so forth and so on
and this book has been a
bestseller I don't know how many million
copies it sold and he's written a sequel
so I said and he's Canadian he's from uh
Fairview Alberta and I'm very familiar
with that area Peace River Region in
Alberta because I did a lot of business
there in Forest Products and I know the
area I know the people some of the
people you know up in that area great
area great country
so I began to read through it and I'd be
interested in the reaction of people who
have read the book uh I sort of leafed
through it
um my reaction is that he has sort of
this tremendous knowledge
of psychology of
mythology of religion
and so he sort of describes
you know a world
that our lives are in his view tragic or
full of evil I mean eventually we die
and there's lots of bad things that
happen
bad things have always happened and so
in this world of chaos then how should
we lead Our Lives
uh in his first chapter which he calls
uh you know a stand up straight with
your shoulders back in other words you
should have a very erect posture and he
ties that in some way to this idea of of
a hierarchy
uh in the animal kingdom hierarchy in
amongst human beings at that structure
or hierarchy is kind of embedded in our
genetic uh you know we're predisposed to
be more dominant or less dominant uh he
even suggests that the chaos portion of
lives is sort of uh and the negative is
female and the order and the yes and the
positive is male and a lot of these
things that I have a lot of trouble uh
accepting
uh and in fact as a general rule I find
that his 12 rules don't really relate to
the subject matter that he discusses
within each chapter he has a chapter for
each rule and so instead you have these
themes that sort of pervade all of these
chapters and that is this sense of sort
of a dark world and the only way we can
survive is if we maintain certain
structures he seems to favor a
patriarchy because
historically and perhaps in the animal
kingdom the male is typically stronger
uh and that's a good thing and where
there is and and all the while of course
he's pushing back against this sort of
woke thing which makes any sort of
expression of power a Bad Thing whereas
in fact to a large extent people who
have more power but not always but in
many cases they have earned that
position of power because they have
certain abilities and so he stresses
this that we can't just condemn the
patriarchy but by the same token
countries that are where the patriarchal
sort of pattern is stronger aren't
necessarily happier countries any survey
of Happiness typically shows countries
like Denmark and Scandinavia is having
the highest happiness coefficient to the
extent that we can measure that
effectively it's somewhat subjective and
those countries typically have sort of a
less dominant patriarchal structure than
some more traditional societies but
nevertheless he does make the point that
the world we live in
is one where you know the individual is
important in fact that's I should go
there right away I saw a video of his I
did some research on the internet
where he makes the point that our
Western Society is very successful and
and so again he's defending
Western Society from those who almost
systematically want to tear it down
fair enough
uh there's definitely a tendency for
intellectuals you know people at
universities to want to tear down the
establisher to criticize the established
order this was the case with the
prevalence of marxists and the economics
Department it's the example today where
in all of the humanities you have this
strong
preponderance of people who are quote
Progressive
and who are therefore very critical of
the established society when in fact
this is the established Society is
really not that bad however where I have
trouble with with Jordan Peterson as he
causes Western Society Western culture
but but the fact is that it's modern
society that Western Society
500 years ago a thousand years ago
over 2000 years ago in Rome in Greece
where half the population were slaves uh
in the Middle Ages when people were
persecuted for what they found for their
religions uh
not that great at a time in many cases
throughout history where other
civilizations it might be you know the
the
Chinese civilization during the uh
the Tang Dynasty for example maybe
Hangzhou was a nicer place to live than
London
uh you know I get my dates but certainly
six you know Middle Ages in Europe was
not that great in terms of lifespan in
terms of the sophistication in terms of
respect for individuals and so forth and
so on uh in the Modern Age a country
like Japan has a legal system which is
uh certainly no worse than uh in Western
Europe or North America it certainly has
Health outcomes that are better it
functions very effectively as a society
so I think this idea of sort of to stick
up for Western society and we're the
best and stuff I find that a little bit
inaccurate to say the least and even to
the extent of the sort of technological
achievements in Western Society they are
the result of
technological advances in other
countries in mathematics in India and
and uh science in China 2000 years ago
and uh even uh
you know Arab and Muslim Scholars who
sort of uh kept Greek learning and
Indian learning and and Islamic learning
and eventually brought that back to the
West so that in say 12 13 14th century
many of these things were rediscovered
and this then led to the Renaissance and
so forth and so on the world is an
interconnected place and I think you
know to use his uh imagery you know to
stand up on your hind legs and say ours
is the best I don't think it's very
helpful I think if he just as I'm now
learning so much more about Iran and
Persian history and and the the Cyrus is
the cylinder where he recognized the
freedom of religion and freedom of of
different ethnic groups groups to have
every right in the in the old Persian
Empire it kind of enables you to see the
world through different lenses the
lenses of different languages and and I
think that gives you a better
perspective you
and uh
but I do agree that that one shouldn't
be overly critical of of our society you
know there's a lot of the sort of
anti-capitalist society but I'm always
aware of the fact that the products that
I use this camera that I'm using which
is made in Japan or maybe it's made in
China under licensed from the Japanese
uh the food I eat the products I use the
daily functioning of our society it's
you know all kinds of people making my
life richer and better that's how our
societies have evolved of course it ends
at some point uh I don't think that
people are all out to get me I don't
think there's so many evil people out
there but there are evil people and so
in terms of how we lead our lives uh I
don't think we should say it's all the
individual it's not all the individual I
think we need to obviously live our
lives in a way that you know we are
responsible for our lives but we are
also helpful to others which is in a way
in his book but it's sort of hidden in
amongst all the sort of dark mythology
and you know biblical references to
punishments and uh and all kinds of dark
stuff he creates this sort of sense that
the world is this uh chaotic place and
the it's sort of difficult to extract
yourself from the tragedy and the pain
of living and to do that you gotta you
know follow these rules basic self-help
things there that are Universal like
tell the truth and listen to others and
uh you know look after yourself be
responsible to yourself and all the
stuff is good and but but uh I think the
main reason why his his book
has been so successful I think there are
two reasons one is there's quite a
breadth of of information about
psychology and and mythology and
religions and all these different ways
that people try to explain the Mystery
of Life
and then he extracts out of that a few
rules he claims that can help mitigate
this this uh chaos and enable you to
live a meaningful life but where that
meeting is you have to find for yourself
I think obviously our families provide
meaning but there are also dysfunctional
families for me learning languages
provide meaning because I discover more
about different cultures uh people who
are bird watchers people who are
involved in Charities there was a
gentleman discovered the other day who
he has set up his whole house as a as a
you know Recycling Depot
and you can take your empty milk bottles
your empty you know water bottles your
empty wine bottles take them up there
drop them there and he will make sure
that that is converted into because the
recycling system pays you for them
and from that he gives food vouchers to
homeless people that's his life that's
meaning he has that's his meaning
wonderful
um
so we find meaning wherever it is like I
uh and and I think where I I agree with
with uh Jordan Peterson is
pushback on all this woke stuff like
this gender neutral
pronouns it doesn't matter if if there
is a non-binary person a transgendered
person and I refer to him or her as him
or her and they said to me no I'd rather
be referred to as this fine
um the idea that somehow a gender
neutral pronoun has some great
significance I don't buy uh in Persian
and in Turkish they have gender neutral
pronouns and yet both of those societies
are more patriarchal and less tolerant
of non-traditional gender roles or
non-traditional sexual orientation so
the fact that uh gender neutral pronoun
is used is meaningless and why you know
whatever the number is of these
non-binary people in our society
I don't know point zero you one percent
two percent whatever the number is why
should everyone have to change their
um
speech patterns to accommodate this the
main purpose is to demonstrate how
Progressive we are see I use my
preferred like just by saying my
preferred pronouns are he and him now
I've said I'm Progressive it's
meaningless actually uh it's like in the
company that I ran we have always hired
the best person available we've had
Japanese people Chinese people seeks
there we've had Romanians Russians uh I
don't know Filipinos we've had gay
people we've had everybody the best
person we can find always but I don't
believe in saying I am a diversity you
know employer I sign on to the diversity
statement I don't need all of that
that's the sort of virtue signaling
rather the principle should be you hire
the best person available and I am
responsible to myself to my employees
and that's how I I so to that extent
making these kinds of virtue signaling
statements a condition of employment or
uh you know the whole Department's set
up to deal with diversity and diversity
is better than lack of diversity for
example that I don't buy that because
Japan Korea Finland they don't have much
diversity and their successful societies
and you have other societies like Canada
if you go to Toronto Vancouver Montreal
you're going to find a tremendous
diversity of religion race and ethnicity
but what really matters is diversity of
points of view and I don't think the
societies that are diverse ethnically or
in terms of gender are necessarily
better
than less diverse but I think it's
probably a good idea to have a diversity
of views and in that regard I think
Jordan Peterson while I find a lot of
his stuff I don't necessarily agree with
it's valuable to have people like that
who are pushing back against this
attempted you know Conformity imposition
on people you must say this you must
make a statement on diversity you must
use gender neutral broadales and so
forth and so on so with that I think
I've stirred up hopefully a bit of
controversy and but I think diversity of
use is important and we should respect
everyone's point of view and be willing
to discuss and defend our views and also
take into consideration the counter
arguments there you have it thank you
for listening bye for now